ce à quoi nous devons nous attaquer
c'est le séparatisme islamistes rédigé
pour conforter les principes
républicains
le projet de loi sur le séparatisme
s'attaque à plusieurs thématiques l'un
des objectif encadrer davantage les
lieux de culte musulman le texte vise
notamment à rendre plus transparentes
leurs comptabilités les dons de plus de
dix mille euros seront soumis à un
régime déclaratif de ressources
un juge pourra également prononcé une
interdiction de paraître dans un lieu de
culte
en cas de condamnation pour provocation
à des actes terroristes à la haine ou à
la violence
l'école à domicile est également dans le
viseur du gouvernement avec le principe
de la scolarisation obligatoire dès
trois ans les parents voulant instruire
leurs enfants à la maison devront
demander une autorisation à l'éducation
nationale le texte s'attaque également
aux mariages forcés les officiers d'état
civil pourront s'entretenir séparément
avec les époux en cas de doute sur leur
libre consentement les certificat de
virginité délivré par certains médecins
seront également interdits la lutte
contre la polygamie est également
renforcée de nouveaux moyens sont aussi
donnés à la lutte contre la haine en
ligne les auteurs de propos haineux sur
internet pourront être jugés en
comparution immédiate
dans son article 25 le projet de loi
punit de trois ans de prison et de 45000
euros damende la mise en danger de la
vie d'une personne en dévoilant des
informations permettant de l'identifier
ou de la localiser la peine est aggravée
lorsque la personne visée est
dépositaire de l'autorité publique ou
chargée d'une mission de service public
une disposition censée prévenir les
actes comme celui qui avait coûté la vie
à samuel pâtit le 16 octobre dernier
présenté en conseil des ministres ce
mercredi soit 115 ans jour pour jour
après l'adoption de la loi de 1905 sur
la séparation des églises et de l'état
le texte devrait être débattu à
l'assemblée nationale au début de
l'année 2000 21